this video is sponsored by the book
summary service
blinkist the first 100 people to use the
link in the description will receive one
free week of unlimited access
plus 25 off a full membership
positioned at the forefront of perhaps
the most significant shift in western
history
having both predicted the cause and
consequence and going on to provide
grandiose
revolutionary ideas as possible
solutions
friedrich nietzsche is one of the most
influential and significant thinkers
of modern history the particular
crossroads that nietzsche stands at is
one where the primary path of western
religious faith
began to crumble and cave in leaving a
massive empty crater at the end of life
suffering
and what would seem like only one
alternative path towards that of
pessimism
and nihilism his life's work would
undertake this newly emerging issue
and attempt to forge a new third path
away from both religious faith and
nihilism
and towards new meaning and human values
nietzsche was born in 1844 in saxony
prussia
which is now part of eastern germany he
was born to a modest family living an
ordinary sheltered early childhood
his father carl ludwig nietzsche was the
town's lutheran pastor
which would immediately immerse young
nietzsche into the christian faith
however simultaneous to being introduced
to it it would soon be challenged and
tested
as his father the same man who practiced
and preached of god
was diagnosed with a terminal brain
disease for a year
his father suffered horribly and then
died at the young age of just 35
and the following year nietzsche's
younger brother ludwig
also died this dichotomy of his
religious foundation and early exposure
to the irreconcilable
reasonless pain and suffering
experienced by good undeserving people
would likely lay some of the groundwork
for what would ultimately become
the basis of nietzsche's later work
following a fairly somber
serious and lonely childhood nietzsche
would go on to study theology
at the university of bonn both in early
schooling and university
he would show strong intellectual
promise excelling especially well in
christian theology
however following just one semester at
university as he became increasingly
critical and intellectually sharp
and after being exposed to various
critiques of christianity
nietzsche would have no choice but to
let go of his christian faith
fully shedding the skin of his innocence
and blind devotion
from here he would go on to study
philology the study of the history of
language
at the university of leipzig here he
would do so well
that while still only in his
mid-twenties he would go on to be hired
as a professor of classical philology at
the university of basel
becoming the youngest professor to ever
be hired still to this day
after only a few years of teaching
though nietzsche would leave his
position
partly because of his growing
dissatisfaction and sense of constraint
within academia and partly because of
his growing poor health which he had
accumulated by a combination of genetic
ailments
and what is believed to have been a case
of syphilis that he contracted at a
brothel
from here he would go on to live a
fairly isolated life
traveling around europe moving to and
from different climates most suitable
for his poor health
and living off a small university
pension he would live primarily and most
notably in the swiss alps
where he would spend the majority of his
remaining sane life
throughout this time in between spells
of being bedridden by his ailments
a devastating failed love ordeal
degrading friendships and family
relations
and depressive and nihilistic states
nietzsche would spend most of his time
walking
thinking and writing finding solace
meaning and reason to continue
through his pursuit of philosophy during
this time
he would produce his most influential
works including
human all to human the gay science thus
spoke zarathustra
beyond good and evil and on the
genealogy of morals
in these works nietzsche would lay both
the groundwork and early constructions
of a new sort of philosophy a philosophy
that would essentially loosen the bolts
of all contemporary certainties
all notions of good and evil all
knowledge of true
and false right and wrong
god is dead god remains dead and we have
killed him
how shall we comfort ourselves the
murderers of all murderers
what was holiest and mightiest of all
that the world has yet owned
has bled to death under our knives is
not the greatness of this deed too great
for us
must we ourselves not become gods simply
to appear worthy of it
this is perhaps one of nietzsche's most
quoted and important passages
it is in this line god is dead that we
find
not nietzsche's celebration of
humanity's lost faith
but his stark intense concern of warning
for what it meant
the collapse of christian faith brought
with it in nietzsche's mind
the collapse of everything built on it
the whole of european morality
its rationales and its values he both
predicted and feared
that with this collective revelation
without sufficient replacement
humanity would be left to struggle with
no clear system or meaning
and devolve into widespread despair in
the form of nihilism
one of nietzsche's key ideas at the
foundation of his attempt to resolve
this issue
is the recognition that there is in fact
no universal objective truth to be known
there are no facts only interpretations
he wrote
nietzsche denied the very construct of
any sort of capital t truth
and suggested that all attempts to find
one were woefully misguided and actually
the source of disconnect preventing
modern man
from rediscovering any meaning in life
the pursuit of universal objectivity
or meaning beyond this life took the
spirit out of the present
earthly human experience of meaning
which is inherently subjective
independent and expressive because of
this nietzsche would direct his
attention primarily to the arts and
humanities
believing that creative acts and
experiences be it things like music
philosophy literature theater and so on
could be used as essential means to
communicate
deeper truths and fill the void of
higher connection and meaning
although as nietzsche explored this
theory he would find that cultural arts
and humanities
were susceptible to becoming dried out
academic
and or commodified often losing their
luster and dependability
from here he would turn his attention
towards creating a philosophy that
detached the individual
from dependence on any collective
experience or cultural mechanisms
and rather focused on the individual
pursuit of creative expression and
subjective greatness
placing the creation of meaning squarely
in the hands of each individual
this philosophy would be embodied in
what nietzsche would term the ubermensch
or overman or sometimes translated as
the superman
which he would first introduce in his
book thus spoke zarathustra
the over man is described as a sort of
defiant confident
independent individual who pursues their
personal desires with vigor
and dignifies their independent beliefs
unapologetically
one who deviates from the collective
exhibits strategic selfishness
and acts with aggressiveness and
grandiose the reason for such
characteristics was justified in
nietzsche's view
by the fact that a new morality that
opposed the moral views rooted in
christianity
which praised weakness and modesty was
needed to better suit the natural
condition of human experience
which he felt was comprised and
requiring of the desire for vigor
power and greatness this view is not
without valid critiques
and invalid misinterpretations however
perhaps what is more important than
nietzsche's image of the over man
is what the concept serves to represent
in slightly broader terms
nietzsche sets up the overman to
function as a sort of idealized version
of oneself
an image of a perfect and powerful being
who has overcome all their fears and
deficiencies
which one can and should set goals to
strive towards
of course as an ideal it cannot ever
truly be reached
but that is functionally the point
nietzsche proposed that the world
including the human operates off of what
he called the will to power
an insatiable desire in each living
being to manifest power
the world is will to power and nothing
besides he wrote
and according to nietzsche this will to
power is manifested in the desire for
personal growth
and satisfied in the pursuance of said
growth
it is important to note here that his
notion of power is not necessarily
referring to physical strength
nor power and dominance over others but
rather
power over oneself psychological and
spiritual strength in the form of
self-mastery and continuous growth
represents the ultimate synchronization
with the will to power for nietzsche
and thus the ultimate synchronization
with life itself
the desire and striving towards the
ideal of the over man
serves as perpetual fuel to this process
of self-growth
as one works through a continued cycle
of self-dissatisfaction
self-improvement and self-rediscovery
over and over
for nietzsche this process which he
would term self-overcoming
is fundamental to answering and
resolving the problem of meaning
and value in life so long as one
establishes their goals of growth
in the name of what they deem an
idealized life-affirming version of
themselves
the process transmutes the suffering of
life into something worthwhile
and personally redeemable a sort of
alchemy of the spirit
that affirms life in the face of its
inevitable suffering
if we have our own why in life we shall
get along with almost any how
nietzsche wrote unlike his primary
predecessor
arthur schopenhauer who proposed that
suffering is best minimized and avoided
to the best of one's ability
nietzsche argued that suffering is
rather a good thing to be leaned into
embraced and used as fuel towards the
amassing of strength
and psychological power life is in fact
inevitable suffering and so
it is not a matter of if but for what
the meaninglessness of suffering not
suffering itself
was the curse that lay over mankind so
far nietzsche wrote
while continuing to write and live an
increasingly isolated life in the
mountains
still in the early stages of some of his
most ambitious philosophical
undertakings
nietzsche would begin to show increasing
signs of declining mental health
at 44 years old after seeing a horse
being flogged in a street by its
owner he experienced a mental breakdown
rushing over to the horse
hugging and consoling it and yelling i
understand you
i understand you this strange episode
which marked his last moments out of
apparent lucidity
appeared to be an act of complete
contradiction to his own philosophy
pity weakness and compassion soon after
nietzsche would dip into complete
madness eventually falling into a state
of catatonia
one of the most powerful minds of modern
history seemingly collapsed under the
weight of itself
whether the cause was organic latent
consequences to his contracted ailments
or the consequence of a mind that
pursued too far into itself
becoming stuck on its way back out is
unknown
before ever coming back out in 1900 at
the young age of 55
nietzsche died of a stroke
during his lifetime according to his own
standards nietzsche might likely be
considered a failure prior to losing his
sanity
he had made very little of himself and
saw very little if not no success
his books didn't sell and he never
really garnered any notable respect or
recognition
but following his death of course his
work would take off
soon gaining massive notice respect and
worldwide following
some of which unfortunately would lead
to horrible misguided
and ill-conceived applications however
today and more generally nietzsche's
work remains potent
important and redeemably ingrained in
modern thinking
his quotes aphorisms and ideas echo
through culture every day
both literally and symbolically and so
in a fittingly ironic way
just how nietzsche suggested that we
must symbolically die throughout life
so that we can get out of our own way
and become who we really are
sometimes sacrificing ourself our
personal preservation
health or sanity in the process of
something greater
perhaps nietzsche's life and death was
just that a process of self-overcoming
towards self-sacrifice towards something
greater
of course nietzsche's ideas aren't
without valid critiques including this
notion of self-overcoming
sacrifice and greatness although his
assessments and predictions of modern
issues are arguably quite accurate
his resolutions aren't necessarily all
serving
his suffering and the continual pursuit
of desire and self-destruction
in the name of growth towards an
unattainable end goal really a good
thing
and how can one see it as a good thing
if they do not
how can one create a life-affirming
interpretation of life
if their interpretation of life is not
affirming in other words if one sees
life as negative or meaningless
to try to create goals or place
themselves on such an interpretation
only brings them back to square one in
need of some truth or meaning beyond
themselves
something other than what one sees has
or experiences
which they cannot have and furthermore
if one does not agree with the initial
premise
that suffering is good in the name of
progress then the rest might merely be
misdirection
of course being a philosopher whose work
doesn't necessarily follow any linear
or systematic structure and can even
contradict itself at times
nietzsche's ideas are open to multiple
interpretations
and of course all the aforementioned is
merely a single
very brief one and more importantly
seeing as how his philosophy
caters to this open-ended nature and is
arguably not a guide to think in a
certain way
but rather a guide to think in one's own
way
nietzsche leaves us the space too even
if we disagree with him
do just as he did and pave a new
direction
for ourselves
[Music]
this video was sponsored by blinkist
few people deny the value of healthy
reading and learning habits
but for most of us it is understandably
difficult to sustain
the negative feedback loop between
feeling like you don't have enough time
to consistently read and learn
and the potential value that reading and
learning could have on reducing
or better managing the sense that you
don't have enough time for things you
value
is unfortunately paradoxical the book
summary service blinkist however
makes escaping this cycle much easier
condensing thousands of non-fiction
books into around 15 minute summaries
that can be read or listened to
even while offline blinkist makes it
easy to absorb and grasp the ideas and
key takeaways
of complete books in a convenient amount
of time whether you're interested in
philosophy
science psychology business art or any
other common non-fiction subjects
blinkist can help just about anyone
better learn and consistently engage in
their curiosities
better yet blinkist now also provides
complete audio books that you can
purchase directly within the app
as well as consolidated summaries of
popular podcasts
allowing you to fully delve into topics
and authors that you find especially
fascinating
if you're interested in learning more
about topics related to philosophy and
western history blinkist has some great
titles including
at the existential cafe by sarah
bakewell which explores the lives and
ideas of popular 20th century
existential thinkers
as well as a brief history of thought by
luke ferry which explores the history
and key developments of western
philosophy more broadly
and how we can apply it to our everyday
lives the first 100 people to use the
link in the description will receive one
free week of unlimited access
as well as 25 off a full membership the
free 7-day trial can be cancelled at any
time within the trial period
again if you're interested please visit
blinkist.com pursuit of wonder or click
the link in the description below
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
you